[Musique]
france inter l'easa l'ennemi nicolas
demorand de 7,9 et avec léa salamé nous
recevons ce matin dans le grand
entretien du 7-9 le nouveau président du
parti les républicains question réaction
amis auditeurs au 01 45 24 7 milles sur
les réseaux sociaux et les applications
mobiles de france inter christian jacob
bonjour bonjour vous voilà donc
président après une élection maréchal ou
presque 63 % des voix contre un peu
moins de 22 au député du vaucluse julien
aubert est un peu plus de 16 au député
de l'yonne guillaume larrivé vous ne
rêviez pas du job
vous l'aviez dit vous vous êtes dévoué
pour sauver le parti après la déroute
des élections européennes que
ressentez-vous ce matin christian jacob
beaucoup ironise comme le quotidien
l'opinion qui fait de vous le premier
corvée je sais pas si vous avez vu la
une ce matin le jeu de mots est bon mais
pas mal quand même mais bon vous vous
ressentez quoi dire un titre de libé
pour l'opinion d'exane allemand c'est
pas mal non écoutez c'est bon beaucoup
de
beaucoup de responsabilités mais en même
temps avec des fondamentaux qui sont qui
sont solides nos fondamentaux c'est
d'abord les territoires nous sommes
majoritaires sur les territoires si on
on prend aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
conseillers municipaux départementaux et
régionaux ce sont les républicains qui
sont majoritaires sur le territoire on
est majoritaire au sénat
ça n'est pas rien non plus sinon je
pense que je ne sais pas dans quelle
dérive institutionnelle en serait nous
avons le premier groupe parlementaire
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale et
est malgré tout toujours une force
militante de relativement dynamique on
l'a vu là avec cette élection puisque on
a un meilleur taux de participation que
là la dernière fois donc les
fondamentaux sont là maintenant
maintenant les bombes les difficultés on
les connaît aussi je pense que vous
allez venir évidemment pardonnez-nous de
voir le verre à moitié vide mais on est
c'est notre job vous vous le voyez à
moitié plein effectivement soixante
mille votants et hier c'est plus que le
taux de croissance et mieux en tant que
toute participation que ce qu'avait fait
laurent wauquiez il ya deux ans mais
tout de même il ya deux ans en 2017
il y avait deux cent trente cinq mille
adhérents chez lr aujourd'hui il n'y en
a plus que 130 milles c'est quand même
quelque chose qui se qui se rapetisse de
plus en plus on avait jean françois copé
qui était à votre place il ya quelques
jours
et à la question à quoi servent les
républicains il a répondu non sans
ironie excellente question je me le
demande pas écouté incarner la droite
moi le peuple de droite il existe en
france et il n'est pas il n'est pas
représenté aujourd'hui par par emmanuel
macron et par le
par la république en marche il suffit de
regarder d'abord l'incapacité qu'il y a
eu à apporter des réformes économiques
si on prend tous les engagements qui
étaient ceux d' emmanuel macron de
baisser la dépense publique
il l'augmenté davantage que ne le
faisait françois hollande de baisser la
dette
elle n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis qu'il
est au pouvoir alors qu'elles diminuent
dans les pays dans les pays voisins
n'ont pas de réformes de structures là
la droite n'est pas incarné aujourd'hui
c'est notre responsablité omis peut
mieux faire peut-être selon vous
christian jacob et le même jean françois
copé toujours au au micro d'inter disait
qu emmanuel macron était le président de
droite que vous n'attendiez plus vous la
droite non moi j'ai jamais attendu
manuel macron honnêtement est revenu sur
vos terres oui oui mais la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui on est plus dans le
discours il ya deux ans et demi qu
emmanuel macron et l'orne il échoue sur
la dépense publique elle elle augmente
comme je le disais à l'instant plus
rapidement que ce soit hollande il ne
désendette pas là les impôts les taux
des prélèvements obligatoires n'ont
jamais été aussi élevés la compétitivité
de nos entreprises se dégrader impôts
mais ce pardon non mais le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires mais les
impôts et l'esprit français
ce qui compte pour les les français
c'est les prélèvements obligatoires
c'est ce qu'on retire de leur poche
parce que les impôts on en bessin on
augmente l'autre et la compétitivité des
entreprises
lorsque françois hollande quitte
l'elysée on a un déficit de 45 milliards
d'euros d'un balance commerciale deux
ans et demi après la politique menée par
monsieur macro 60 milliards d'euros
donc on a un déficit de notre balance
commerciale qui se creuse ce qui veut
dire que toutes les réformes qui étaient
annoncés n'ont pas été réalisés aucune
n'a été réalisé et c'est le reproche que
nous pouvons faire aujourd'hui et c'est
pour ça que ça n'est pas une réponse à
aux attentes à la fois des électeurs de
droite mais aussi beaucoup d'autres
électeurs qui ont sans doute cru parce
que aux promesses des manuels macron
parce que effectivement comme vous le
disiez un certain nombre de promesses
sonnait bien à l'oreille des des gens de
droite mais maintenant on y est encore
il ya quatre mois puisque aux élections
européennes il a pris 30% des électeurs
dont ils soient filles ont donc ceci
étant vous savez comme moi que c'est
difficile de comparer les élections
européennes avec une autre élection
tout simplement parce que ce n'est pas
avec les élections européennes qu'on va
porter des réformes internes en france
des trois questions encore sur votre
parti et puis ensuite on va passer aux
questions d'actualité pour entendre
aussi votre différence avec la politique
d' emmanuel macron peut-être gérard
larcher ou une primaire ouverte à droite
pour la présidentielle de 2002 22 xavier
bertrand n'en veut pas quelle est votre
position
je suis toujours été opposé à la
primaire je lé était avant-hier et hier
et aujourd'hui je pense que cette
primaire que c'est en règle générale
quand on en importe des solutions de la
gauche ça nous réussit rarement et ce
système qui consiste à dire il faut il
faut d'abord divisé pour mieux
rassembler après on envie de dire et si
on rassemblait tout de suite pour ce qui
vous concerne la présidentielle 2022
pour vous c'est non et bien non en oui
je pense y a pas beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'ambiguïté sur ce sujet vous
riez à deux jours de votre candidature
pour la la la la tête du parti vous
étiez à ce micro et vous nous disiez que
non vous ne seriez pas candidat je sais
pas si c'est à deux jours mais avouez
que bon personne n'avait pu anticiper la
décision de le révoquer les républicains
détiennent sur leur seule couleur un
tiers des villes de plus de 9000
habitants ça fait 300 villes environ
quel est votre objectif pour les
prochaines municipales
combien de villes de rester majoritaires
sur les territoires c'est clairement
notre notre objectif c'est un enjeu
déterminant pour nous les les élections
municipales parce que ce sera notre
premier rendez vous électoral après les
européennes
nous sommes majoritaires sur les
territoires et nous devons nous devons
le rester parce que nous incarnons et et
nous maires qui sont en place incarne un
savoir faire et une confiance avec leurs
concitoyens qui je pense sera renouvelée
en tout cas pour nous c'est un enjeu
déterminant et moi j'entends que nous
nous mobilisions maximum pour préparer
ces élections municipales une mères
voilées accompagnant son enfant lors
d'une sortie scolaire au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté a
été violemment prise à partie par le
président du groupe fn au conseil julien
odoul qui lui a demandé de retirer son
voile
les conseillers du rassemblement
national ont ensuite quitté l'hémicycle
ce qui s'est passé est ce que ça vous a
choqué jeu sur l'action son hôte oui en
revanche sur le fait qu'elle quelle soit
voilée oui ça me choque
que parce que bon le nous avons c'est
d'ailleurs jacques chirac qui avait pris
le premier la la loi d'interdiction du
voile dans les établissements dans les
établissements publics là c'est un
accompagnement à ce sujet bien c'est ce
que nous avions pris nous avec une
directive qui avait été prise par luc
chatel à l'époque et moi dans laquelle
je me retrouvais bien c'est à dire que
s'il est liée à l'interdiction du voile
à l'école
il faut qu'il soit également interdite
dans l'accompagnement des voyages
scolaires de la même façon et la loi
doit être appliquée mais ce qui s'est
passé avec le le conseiller régional en
aura centre national on peut le faire
sans agresser les gens mais en revanche
moi ça me choque quand qu'on accepte
effectivement qu'une personne voilée
puisse accompagner des enfants
déplacements scolaires parce que comment
expliquer que ces interdits dans
l'enceinte de l'établissement mais que
si on est au contact des enfants en
dehors et toujours dans le cadre
scolaire puisque c'est un voyage de
scolaires qu'on l'autorisé jean michel
blanquer remise de l'éducation dit un
peu comme vous il dit qu'il préférait
qu'une mères accompagnatrices ne porte
pas de voile mais qu'il ne veut pas
l'interdire pour autant oui mais on ne
sort de l'ambiguïté qu'à ses dépenses
c'est à dire soit moi c'est pour ça que
la décision qui avait été prise par luc
chatel était la bonne on l'interdît
parce que sinon on est toujours dans
l'ambiguïté et on sait jamais comment
réagir et c'est ce qui se passe c'est
d'ailleurs le problème de ce
gouvernement qui est incapable de
trancher sur ces sujets c'est à dire que
vous lui dites d'interdire clairement le
voile et oui ça à partir du moment où
l'interdît à l'école pour moi savons
pour le tout le temps scolaire et le
temps scolaire c'est le temps qui est
dans l'école mais c'est aussi le tort
d'une sortie scolaire et après on va
nous dire et quand les élèves vont faire
du sport et ils vont dans un
dans un gymnase ou ailleurs et qui sont
et qui sont accompagnés le problème se
posera si on n'est pas claire sur ce
sujet du voile effectivement le
l'ambiguïté fait qu'on se trouve dans
cette situation conflictuelle que nous
sommes christian jacob une semaine après
le débat sur l'immigration voulue par
emmanuel macron qu'en reste-t-il selon
vous rien d'ailleurs ce dépôt fait pour
qu'il en reste quelque chose c'était une
opération de communication avec monsieur
macro c'est quand même formidable on a
entendu ce rouleau compresseur
médiatique pendant quinze jours
attention le président de la république
se saisit du dossier immigration alors
là vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir
effectivement il a fait quelque chose de
formidable personne ne s'y attendait
personnes l'attendait à ce niveau il a
organisé à l'assemblée nationale un
débat sans vote
bravo le premier ministre qui n'exclut
pas des quotas d'immigration
enfin c'était plus il n'exclut pas ne
s'interdit pas de réfléchir à l'idée
vous savez c'est comme coluche lorsqu'il
disait dans les musiques dans les
milieux autorisés on s'autorise à dire à
réfléchir c'est du vent c'est du vent et
je trouve que ça n'est pas sérieux sur
un sujet comme celui là de la bordée de
cette manière c'est à dire à grands
coups de com est en réalité en ne
faisant rien on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
on a à la fois les demandes d'asile qui
explosent alors qu'ils diminuent dans
les zones aux pays voisins au sein de
l'union européenne on a les titres des
demandes de titres de séjour qui
continuent également à progresser sur
les déboutés du droit d'asile on est à
90 ou 95 % des gens qui ne sont pas
accompagnés aux frontières donc d'abord
la loi n'est pas appliquée et ensuite je
pense qu'il y aurait besoin d'avoir plus
de mesures restrictives
nous avons d'ailleurs nous propose est
allé à cette occasion on en parlait tout
à l'heure dans les journaux et à votre
micro léa salamé 785 femmes et enfants
de djihadistes étrangers se seraient
enfuis christian jacob 50 des places de
déplacés à la faveur de l'as au turc au
nord de la syrie la question est
difficile on va pas chercher nier à
polémiquer ni à la réduire d alternative
simple qu'est ce qu'on fait je vous la
pose avec simplicité et gravité
qu'est-ce qu'on
fait est ce qu'il ne faut pas mieux
avoir ces djihadistes ou leurs proches
ici en france en prison si nécessaire
plutôt que de les voir s'éparpiller dans
une zone de guerre
vous avez comme moi que s'ils sont en
prison on a en france on a un autre
risque c'est celui de radicalisation en
prison
le fait de les retrouver aussi à
certains moments en liberté nous nous
avions fait une proposition moi je la
maintiens qui est celle de la création
de tribunaux à 1 un tribunal
international et je pense que c'est une
nécessité parce qu'on voit bien la
difficulté qu'il y a de le confier un
certain nombre de pays qui ne sont pas
sur ceux sur le plan de la de la justice
et de la sécurité
mais l'autre difficulté aussi pour pour
des gens qui ont porté les armes contre
contre la france qui ont qui ont tué des
portés et contribuer à réaliser des
attentats qu'ils reviennent sur le sol
français considèrent qu'ils n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas leur place et c'est
pour ça que l'idée donner vie aux
acteurs nationaux il est la bonne
des tribunaux internationaux très bien
en ce moment il ya une guerre il dit a
dit ce qu'ils sont en train de fuir les
prisons de s'éparpiller qui sont
aujourd'hui dans la nature dont créer
des tribunaux si vous étiez au pouvoir
aujourd'hui vous feriez quoi parce que
là c'est s'est pas créé des mobinautes
bien sûr aujourd'hui ont d'abord depuis
cinquante fait rien il ya une
inconséquence total de la diplomatie
française et occidentale
c'est à dire à vouloir mettre les russes
au banc des accusés et ne pas avoir pris
d'initiatives européennes et
occidentales plus largement en
collaboration avec les russes voilà à
quelles situations ça ça nous amène
ensuite sur le reste je pense
qu'effectivement il y a urgence à une
initiative européenne et en cela moi je
soutiens l'action du président de la
république auprès d'angela merkel mais
il faut que ça se traduise rapidement
par cette initiative européenne
mais qu'on le fasse avec les russes sur
sur ce secteur géographique il n'y aura
pas de solution sans un travail étroit
avec la russie il faut l'accepter faut
se sortir de ce jeu de dupes avec les
russes on est en ligne avec
avec robert depuis mantes-la-jolie la
parole aux auditeurs de france inter à
8h36 bonjour robert bonjour madame
bonjour messieurs bienvenue je vous
écoute on vient aussi de prendre mon
appel maison oui juste en commentaire
est une question très rapide le
commentaire sur le déficit de la
commerce de notre de notre quotidien ou
la balance commerciale ou déficit en
général doivent doit-on rappeler à
monsieur jacob que nicolas sarkozy alors
candidat et leur président de la
république la creuse et d'une manière
avis salle pendant son quinquennat
ça c'est être un commentaire l'autre ma
question beaucoup plus rapide fait que
pense monsieur jacob de la porosité qui
devient de plus en plus importante a été
donné dans un récent sondage entre le
parti des républicains et le
rassemblement national où semble-t-il un
grand nombre de nos adhérents et leur
souhaite un rassemblement avec les ailes
merci robert pour cette question
christian jacq vous répondre ou
l'orosité l air est elle juste
rapidement sur la première
la première question je rappelle que la
situation dans laquelle on était on est
en 2008 avec une crise internationale
sans précédent et la réalité de l'action
menée par monsieur macron c'est
qu'aujourd'hui elle se dégrade par
rapport à la situation de françois
hollande françois hollande quitté
l'élysée avec un déficit de la balance
commercial de 45 milliards d'euros
monsieur macro on nous explique qu'il
renoue avec il renforce la compétitivité
des entreprises la réalité c'est que le
chiffres de la balance commerciale
continue à se dégrader
je rappelle que dans la même période on
doit être à 300 milliards d'excédents en
allemagne et que nous on a 60 milliards
de déficit mais c'est ça ce serait dur
car on est nourri toujours là la balance
depuis des années la balance commerciale
allemande a été et non mais bien si dans
le vert et nous aurons bien se dire
après bien sûr simplement l'action
formidable menée par monsieur macron
fait que la compétitivité des
entreprises se dégradent beaucoup plus
vite que sous françois hollande ça c'est
une réalité incontestable ensuite sur
l'autre sujet écoute et je crois qu'il
n'y a pas d'ambiguïté on a toujours été
très clair sur la ligne qui était la
note de de porosité avec
le rassemblement national où le front
national avant le sujet ait tranché
depuis très longtemps chez nous et le
résultat de l'élection d'hier le prouve
encore s'il le fallait on est en ligne
avec mélissa bonjour et bienvenue
bonjour votre émission je vais être
assez qu'on cible moi je suis notamment
format triturant valeurs de la
république et d'égalité et j'aimerais
beaucoup demandé à monsieur jacob quelle
est la définition de la laïcité et
notamment des libertés pour faire écho à
ce qui s'est passé tout en franche comté
et de cette maman du coup qui a été
agressée du fait qu'elle portait un
signe ostentatoire
merci mélissa dont le même espace la
question de pascal aussi bonjour et
bienvenue pascal oui bonjour je vous
appelle parce que j'ai en fait j'ai été
un peu choqué parce que monsieur jacob à
aucun moment ne fait référence à la loi
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui et qui
permet à des mamans voilées et encore
faut voir de quelle voix 10 h il ya des
différences entre les voiles
d'accompagner les sorties scolaires
aujourd'hui la loi et celle là et
j'insiste encore une fois sur le degré
d'ouverture que ça peut permettre à tous
les gens d'aller voir des spectacles de
sortir de s'aérer qu'est ce qu'on veut
on veut des mamans à la maison des jeux
sera très content on va parler de
stigmatisation je trouve que
stratégiquement c'est une erreur et je
suis mais franchement le nom rappel à la
loi en disant que c'était lui bah
finalement il avait fait cette remarque
mais comme elle avait été fait
violemment c'est ça qui posait problème
non non le problème c'est que c'était
lui n'a pas respecté la loi je ne
comprends pas cette espèce d'entre-deux
monsieur jacob
merci pascal pour cette question merci
mélissa également christian jacob vos
réponses écoutez sur l'ambiguïté de la
loi je les dis moi je considère qu'il
faut avoir une position très claire sur
ce sujet et je vois pas comment
effectivement on interdit le voile dans
l'enceinte scolaire est en revanche
pendant le temps scolaire
si on sort de l'enceinte ont
l'autorisent
on est dans une situation ambiguë le le
ministre blanc caire
l'adie et c'est pour ça que moi j'ai une
position beaucoup plus tranché sur ce
sujet pour éviter toute ambiguïté le
port du voile n'est pas interdit en
france il est interdit dans les
établissements publics et pendant le
pendant le temps scolaire je considère
qu'il doit l'être
on est en ligne non parce qu'elle n'est
plus avec nous on est en ligne avec
marie thérèse bienvenue bonjour marie
thérèse je n'accorde critique assez
durement la politique de monsieur macro
et en même temps il refuse de se
présenter à la présidentielle
alors je trouve qu'il ya là à l'actrice
un anachronisme
oui peut-être un paradoxe si marie
thérèse vous savez qu'on peut vous aurez
très bien vivre sans être candidat à la
présidentielle je vous le confirme et on
peut avoir un engagement politique être
mobilisés et est motivé et c'est ce que
je suis aujourd'hui à la à la tête de
mât de ma famille politique et puis
viendra le temps des ambitions
individuelles croyez-moi ce moment là on
ne manquera pas en revanche aujourd'hui
le travail des républicains c'est un
travail de fond pour répondre aux
attentes de nos compatriotes
on a besoin de redevenir audible et
crédible
et ça ça passe par le travail de fond et
non pas par cultiver les ego des uns et
des autres ce n'est pas le moment pour
ça sur l'application de france inter ce
télé vannes vous pose la question
suivante pour les municipales quels
choix pour nice et marseille où deux
candidats aient l'air se présente
écoutez ça on l'évoquera en commission
d'investiture il ya d'autres endroits
nous aurons à l'étranger vous comprenez
pas c'est pas moi qui l'ait je
contribuerai bien évidemment et tranchée
mais ça se fait en commission
d'investiture et on va prendre le temps
de le faire mais c'est le cas à chaque
élection municipale stéphane vous pose
la question suivante est-ce que vous
validez accepter un candidat les
républicains avec l'appui officiel de la
république en marche risque de confusion
voire de compromission pour
l'interrogation
je pense que nous devons être candidat
sous nos couleurs c'est à dire pas
d'accord politique avec la république en
marche pas plus d'ailleurs et encore
moins avec le rassemblement national
ensuite les maires nous nous
investissons des mères qui eux vont
choisir leurs équipes moi j'étais maire
élu et réélu à trois reprises ce n'est
jamais une commission d'investiture qui
m'a expliqué comment je composais même
ma liste mais à partir du moment où il y
aura un accord politique ce n'est pas
acceptable pour nous sur la pma
christian jacob le groupe votre groupe
lr et diviser vos deux concurrents à la
présidentielle à la présidence du parti
acheter un peu rapide à la présidence de
l'air ont manifesté avec les opposants à
la pma vous vous n'avez pas manifestés
mais vous êtes contre et vous votre et
contre ces divisions ne se sont-elles
pas le signe de votre impossibilité
désormais de parler d'une même voix et
d'avoir des valeurs communes parce qu'on
voit bien que le parti n'a pas de ligne
sur cette question de la paix m
non pas du tout d'ailleurs vous verrez
ce sera sans doute le cas depuis deux
ans depuis deux ans et demi 90% des
députés aient l'air votre 90% des textes
de la même façon et ce sera cela on est
sur un sujet qui touche vraiment alain
team de 2 chacun et à partir de à partir
de là moi je ne vois pas donner de
consigne de consigne de vote
parce que chacun en fonction de sa
propre histoire peut avoir une vision
différente des choses mais ne fait pas
d'eux j'ai pas beaucoup de doutes sur le
fait que très majoritairement les
députés et les républicains feront de la
même façon et oui c'est pas des sujets
où vous êtes pour vous êtes content on
tranche comme ça il faut prendre le
temps de la réflexion c'est ce que nous
avons fait d'ailleurs avec un un débat
qui a été mené avec beaucoup de
sérieuses qui était totalement différent
dit long lock lorsqu'il ya eu le débat
du mariage pour tous portés par par
madame taubira là nous on a eu un débat
apaisé avec des convictions qui se sont
opposés qui sont affrontés
il était opposé qu'il était apaisé le
débat oui j'ai eu à débattre et j'ai
bien entendu on est avec des gens de 2,2
de conviction donc il ya eu des moments
de tension mais c'est normal dans
l'hémicycle il faut il faut accepter ça
en revanche chacun a pu s'écouter se
parler et confronter ses idées ce qui
n'était pas le cas la dernière fois et
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
j'étais allé manifester vous savez moi
je fais partie des des parlementaires
qui ont sans doute le plus battu le pavé
parce que j'étais pendant 20 ans
syndicaliste agricole donc des
manifestations j'en ai fait j'en ai
organisé et je considère que en tant que
parlementaire ça n'est pas ma place
d'aller au même participé à une
manifestation jeu le jeu les faits une
fois au moment du mariage pour tous
parce qu'il n'ya plus moyen de débattre
avec madame taubira temps le débat était
effectif et ce n'était plus possible
mais autrement tant qu'il y ait un débat
sera l'assemblée c'est à l'assemblée qui
doit se tenir
dernière question pour un candidat
français à la commission européenne ce
le fait sans précédent
le rejet de la candidature de sylvie
goulard jeudi dernier est il un
règlement de comptes politique contre
emmanuel macron notamment de la droite
européenne
c'est le résultat d'une arrogance que
l'on connaît bien emmanuel macron c'est
à dire que
il il décide sens en compte sans
concertation sans consultation et puis
avec un message qui était difficile à
porter ce que demandait à sylvie goulard
de se retirer de quitter le gouvernement
parce qu'il y avait des des affaires
judiciaires elle sort du gouvernement
dit mais c'est pas grave on range pour
aller à la commission européenne
d'imposer un premier problème
le deuxième sujet c'est que je pense
pour que les commissaires européens il
faut avoir un profil beaucoup plus
politique et non pas de purs techno
parce que aujourd'hui on l'a bien vu aux
élections non dans tous les pays de
l'union européenne ya une demande de
proximité des commissaires européens et
nous c'est le moment qu'ont choisi pour
envoyer quelqu'un caceres des qualités
mais deux de pures techno et donc
effectivement devant le parlement
européen il y avait de grandes chances
que ça ne passe pas et ça n'a pas passé
je pense que enfin j'ose espérer que le
président de la république en tient
retiendra la leçon pour être un peu
moins arrogant les fois prochaines
merci monsieur le président président du
parti l'est républicain christian jacob
au micro de france inter ce matin passé
une très belle journée